Hello there, I'm Gav.
Welcome to this Slow Mo Guys video.
This one is sponsored by Mio.
It's a water enhancer that
when you squirt into a nice cup
of water, you get very visually
appealing, colorful flume,
reminiscent of our ink in the water video
from a few years ago.
Today, we'll be taking
inspiration from that
and recreating a classic
science experiment.
Replacing the glass of
water with this massive tank
and dropping molten thermite into it,
recording it obviously
at over a thousand frames a second in 4K.
The next thing I'm gonna do
is get into some safety gear
and tell you not to try this at home.
I don't really know how you would though.
This here is our lovely pot of thermite.
Whenever I ask the question,
how bright is thermite,
the answer seems to be, yes.
So what we're gonna do is a small test.
I'm gonna learn a lot
about how bright it is,
what I should be exposing for.
Currently, I'm at F8
on a 90 degree shutter,
at 1,000 frames a second.
So let's see how bright this truly is.
Okay, as you can see, thermite
is indeed very bright,
completely blown out at an F8.
So for this next shot, I
exposed F16 to the point
where it looks like this
was filmed at night,
even though it's a bright
sunny day and only now,
am I seeing any information
in those molten blobs.
What we're using here is
the most common combination
of materials to make thermite,
and that is very finely
ground up aluminium
and iron oxide, which is
pretty much just rust powder.
We've learned a lot of
good things from the test.
I'm happy with my exposure, ISO 320,
90 degree shutter, F 16,
unheard of F stop for me doing this.
The thermite will melt through
this pot, go into the water,
the sand will hopefully
stop it from melting
through the bottom of the tank.
This is a plastic tank
that is slightly leaking,
so not sure how many gos
we'll get from this tank.
This footage is actually
slightly different
to footage of if you're just
pouring molten metal into water.
If you've ever seen that,
you'll notice that as the
molten liquid descends,
it cools down, it becomes more red
and eventually sort of just stacks up
as solid metal on the bottom.
The thermite, the reaction
continues all the way down.
It remains molten, even
after it lands on the sand.
The reaction here isn't
actually using any oxygen
from the surrounding air
and it's not creating CO2
as a byproduct.
What we're doing, is
transferring the oxygen
from the iron oxide to the aluminium,
and that is a massive exothermic reaction.
The two reaction products
that we're left with,
which is just plain old
iron and aluminium oxide,
end up over 2000 degrees
celsius, hence the brightness.
Slightly different effect
when it lands in water,
there's a lot of extra
bubbles and gunk coming out
along with the thermite.
So in order to see a
little bit more of that,
I'm just gonna expose for the sky.
So this will be very bright thermite,
but you'll be able to
see everything around it.
So we know that this reaction
is just a direct transfer
between the two materials involved,
and it's not creating
any gases as a byproduct.
So the bubbles are actually just a result
of the insane temperatures
immediately flashing
the surrounding water to steam,
and especially in this shot on the right,
you can see the insane
amount of steam bubbles
being produced by the heat
of the molten thermite.
The water itself doesn't
actually quench the reaction,
so you kind of just have to wait it out.
And at the end, you're just left
with very brittle pieces of iron.
Well, I think we've got all the shots
that I wanted to see.
Some lovely looking footage.
However, slight problem,
we do have 10 pounds
of thermite left over that I
don't really want to take home,
so we just put it in a tin can,
and we're just gonna get
rid of it all at once.
For reference, everything
we've done so far
has been no bigger than three pounds.
You need quite a lot of heat to start
this thermite reaction, the
little thing you're seeing
sticking out the side of the can there,
is a small magnesium strip.
It's honestly a lot going on here.
You can see that the thermite
reaction has started,
but a lot of the powder
has fallen under the water
and is now exploding
back out like a volcano.
Interestingly, if I wind it back,
look at how quickly the side
of this can becomes molten.
So the reaction has just started
once all these sparks clear
out of the way, just around
where it's being held in place,
it's already glowing.
So in real time, that is
around a third of a second
that this can became liquid basically,
causing it just to give up and fall in.
Well, I think we've ended
up with some wonderful,
artsy looking footage there,
very satisfying to look at.
I could watch that for ages.
Now I'd love to tell you about the sponsor
of this video Mio, and
as you listen to me,
please enjoy these lovely slow-mo clips
of me squeezing some Mio into some water.
Mio may be small, but
it packs a mighty punch
with a cheeky little squeeze,
you can add some incredibly
bold flavors to your water.
You can see me here
blasting a few of them in,
and you'll be glad to
know, every Mio flavor
is zero calories.
You do have to drink quite
a lot of water every day
to stay properly hydrated,
so if you've grown bored of
the flavorless taste of water,
Mio is pretty perfect
for adding to each glass
and encouraging you to drink
your full recommended amount
of water every day.
Very pretty colors, very
satisfying to look at.
Big thanks to Mio for
sponsoring this video.
If you want to get ahold of some yourself,
there's a link in the description,
and big thanks to you
for watching this video.
Make sure you subscribe and
we've got a second channel,
if you wish.
I'll see you next time.